I washed out of Philly This Strange Land
was my last chance
okay we can work on that release date
had bad experiences with Outsiders okay
let's make this place look and feel like
Ohio they spoke in a foreign
but they embrace me as their own let me
show you
the way of the cat teams
[Music]
for the first time in eons all four
clads had a chance you either die a hero
or live long enough to become a panther
got attacked the pack we also need the
Seahawks to lose to the Rams nerds with
your mythology
why are you all blue cats aren't blue
how does that Cat y'all meow but the
Titans were coming for us wait who's
driving this thing
[Music]
think like them
man what the hell are you doing with
your ponytail Hold the Line
water
oh God these special effects are too
realistic
foreign
teams have kept the cat teams at Bay
most the Eagles Clan do everything yeah
our bad fam fix it all right hey coach
Kingsbury see that Cliff no no no no no
I am Cliff whoa
oh whoops I pushed you out